HE'S MY FRIEND.
>> I LOOK AT HIM LIKE -- CHRIS,
I'LL ASK YOU A QUESTION ONE
THING.
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
>> PLEASE.
>> YOU WERE IN NORTH KOREA?
>> NO I HAVEN'T BEEN THERE.
I'LL GO WITH YOU.
>> YOU GO WITH ME.
I'LL GIVE YOU THIS OPPORTUNITY
NOW ON NATIONAL TV, ON NATIONAL
TV, I WILL TAKE YOU OVER THERE
AND INTRODUCE YOU TO HIM.
>> GREAT.
.
IT YOU TO COME BACK HERE AND
TELL THE WORLD, TELL THE WORLD
IN "PERSON TO PERSON" IS HE A
NICE GUY WHEN YOU MEET HIM.
WHEN YOU MEET HIM.
NOT POLITICS.
WHEN YOU MEET HIM AND SIT DOWN
AND HAVE DINNER WITH HIM.
I WANT YOU TO COME -- I'M GIVING
YOU AND INVITATION.
>> I TAKE THE INVITATION.
I TAKE THE INVITATION.
>> I WANT YOU TO GO OVER THERE
AND SEE WITH YOUR OWN EYES.
I'M NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
POLITICS.
IF HE DOES THESE THINGS --
>> THERE'S NO IF.
>> I DON'T GO TO THE CAMPS.
I DON'T DO ANYTHING.
>> THAT'S YOUR CHOICE.
BUT THEY ARE THERE.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
THAT'S GREAT.
I'M SORRY.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO APOLOGIZE
FOR IT.
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT.
I'M JUST SAYING YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU MAKE THIS
MAN INTO SOMETHING HE'S NOT IT
UPSENT PEOPLE.
THAT'S IT.
I TAKE YOUR INVITATION.
LET'S SEE HOW I FEEL WHEN I MEET
HIM.
I'LL GO WHENEVER YOU WANT.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED, I'LL TELL
YOU THIS, DENNIS AS CLOSE AND AS
TIGHT AS YOU ARE WITH THIS MAN I
WOULD BE SURPRISED IF THEY LET
ME COME WITH YOU.
I WOULD BE SURPRISED.
YOU HAVE TO ASK WHY.
WHY DON'T WE WANT THIS GUY?
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
PLEASE, PEOPLE TAKE THIS IN THE
RIGHT WAY.
I'M NOT TRYING TO TAKE THE
SPOTLIGHT AWAY FROM THE SUPER
BOWL.
IT'S A GREAT WEEK FOR PEOPLE IN
NEW YORK AND AROUND THE WORLD.
GREAT WEEKEND.
BUT I WANT TO COME ON AND SAY
THIS BECAUSE I WANT PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND THIS.
YOU KNOW, I'M NOT A TRAITOR.
I'VE NEVER BEEN A TRAITOR.
I WANT TO MAKE PEOPLE HAPPY IN
THE WORLD.
THAT'S MY GOAL.
IS TO MAKE PEOPLE HAPPY.
I'VE DONE EVERYTHING IN THE
WORLD BETWEEN THE TIME I WAS
BORN TO 52 YEARS OLD.
I'M STILL LIVING.
I'M SO HAPPY THE FACT I GOT
GREAT PEOPLE AROUND ME.
>> PEOPLE BELIEVE IN YOU.
>> PEOPLE BELIEVE IN ME.
>> PEOPLE THINK YOU HAVE A GOOD